WARFARE IS PART OF A BROAD
CAMPAIGN AND NOT RETALIATION
FOR THE SYRIA AIRSTRIKES.
TOMORROW IS TAX DAY WHICH
MEANS IF YOU HAVE NOT YET
COMPLETED YOUR TAX RETURN,
YOU ARE PROBABLY WORKING ON
IT RIGHT NOW.
THE PROCESS HAS NOT CHANGED
MUCH THIS YEAR.
BUT NEXT YEAR AFFECTS TO THE
PRESIDENT'S TAX LAW WILL
BECOME MORE APPARENT.
CORRESPONDENT PETER DOOCY
TELLS US HOW.
>> EVEN THOUGH THE INK ON
THE TAX REFORM BILL HAS BEEN
DRY FOR FOUR MONTHS, THE
ANNUAL MID APRIL HEADACHE,
MILLIONS OF AMERICANS GET
AROUND THE TIME OF THE IRS
FILING DEADLINE IS NOT GOING
ANYWHERE YET.
>> THIS IS THE LAST TIME
YOU'RE GOING TO FILL OUT
THAT LONG, COMPLICATED,
HORRIBLE RETURN.
>> DO YOU GUYS HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS?
>> FOR MOST TAXPAYERS, TAX
DAY 2018 WON'T BE
DRAMATICALLY DIFFERENT THAN
PREVIOUS YEARS, BECAUSE THE
NEW LAW PASSED TOWARDS THE
END OF TAX YEAR 2017.
SO THE NEW RULES KICK IN
NEXT YEAR.
>> ONE PAGE.
IT MAY GET LITTLE BIT
BIGGER, BUT IT WILL SIMPLE
AND EASIER TO DO.
>> NEXT YEAR'S FILINGS WILL
ALSO FINALLY REFLECT LOWER
RATES, FEWER BRACKETS, AND A
STANDARD DEDUCTION NEARLY
TWICE THE SIZE OF THIS
YEAR'S.
>> INDIVIDUALS WILL BE ABLE
TO DEDUCT MORE AGAINST THEIR
TAXABLE INCOME THAN THEY
WOULD HAVE PREVIOUSLY.
THIS MAY MEAN LOWER TAX
BILLS.
BUT ALSO IT MAY MEAN THAT A
LOT OF INDIVIDUALS MAY NOT
HAVE TO ITEMIZE THEIR
DEDUCTIONS ANYMORE.
>> CUTS FOR INDIVIDUALS RUN
THROUGH 2025 WHILE CORPORATE
CUTS ARE PERMANENT.
A PROBLEM FOR DEMOCRATIC
CRITICS.
>> G.O.P. TAX SCAM WAS THE
FUTURE OF OUR SENIORS AND
OUR FAMILIES AND OUR
CHILDREN IN ORDER TO GIVE
EVEN MORE MONEY TO WALL
STREET, PHARMACEUTICAL
COMPANIES, BIG CORPORATIONS
AND THE WEALTHIEST 1%.
>> REPUBLICAN HOUSE WAYS AND
MEANS COMMITTEE CHAIRMAN
KEVIN BRADY WRITES IN
"U.S.A. TODAY" WHILE WE ARE
IN THE MIDST OF THIS YEAR'S
FRUSTRATING TAX SEASON
FILING UNDER THE BROKEN TAX
CODE THINGS LOOK BRIGHT NEXT
YEAR.
NEXT YEAR COULDABLE THE YEAR
THAT CITIZENS SEE THEIR
APRIL TAX BILL DISAPPEAR.
>> MUCH BIGGER EXEMPT
AMOUNT.
BIGGER STANDARD DEDUCTIONS.
THEY MIGHT HAVE CHILDREN AND
TAX CREDITS.
WHAT YOU MIGHT SEE NEXT YEAR
SOME PEOPLE FILING AND
THINKING WAIT, I DON'T OWE
ANYTHING.
THIS IS FANTASTIC.
>> IT WOULD BE QUITE A
CHANGE IF PEOPLE ARE INDEED
PLEASED TO GET A LETTER FROM
THE IRS.
THE TAX COLLECTOR HAS A LONG
WAY TO GO TO GET THERE.
THE ACTING COMMISSIONER SAYS
NEW LANGUAGE IN THE NEW LAW
MEANS THEY HAVE GOT TO MAKE
CHANGES TO 450 DIFFERENT